in the last video we talked about how
the cell uses a sodium potassium pump
and ATP to maintain its potential
difference between the inside of the
cell or the inside of the neuron and the
outside and in general the outside is
more positive than the inside you have a
minus 70 millivolts
difference from the inside to the
outside and it's minus because the
outside is more positive more positive
or less positive minus more positive you
get a negative number and it's by minus
70 now I said that this was the
foundation for understanding how neurons
actually transmit signals and to
understand that I'll kind of lay a
foundation over that foundation I think
then just the actual neuron transmission
will make a lot of sense and even better
it'll make a lot of sense of why they
even have these myelin sheets and these
nodes of ranvier and why we have all of
these dendrites hopefully they'll all
fit together so there are two types of
thing ways that kind of a potential can
travel so there's two types of signal
transfer I'll just call it signal I'll
just call it signal transfer I don't
know what the best word for it is the
first one I'll talk is electrotonic it
sounds very fancy but you'll see it's a
very simple idea electro electro let me
see electro electro tronic electrotonic
potential and the other one i'm going to
go over is an action potential and they
both have their own positives and
negatives in terms of being able to
transmit a signal action potential and
we're talking about within the context
of in a cell or across a cell membrane
so let's understand what these means so
let me get my membrane of a cell let's
say it's a nerve cell or neuron just to
be just to make it all fit together in
this context and we know it's more
positive on the outside than the inside
we know that there's a lot of sodium on
the outside or a lot more sodium on the
outside then they on the inside there
might be a little bit and we know
there's a lot more potassium on the
inside there's a lot more potassium on
the inside than the outside but we know
generally that the outside is more
positive than the inside because our
sodium potassium pump will pump out
three sodium's for every two but
assumes it takes in now in the last
video I told you that there are these
things called well we could call them a
sodium gate a sodium ion gate right
these are all ions they're charged now
let's say that there's some reason some
stimulus let me label this this is my
scroll down a little bit this right here
that right there is my sodium ion gate
and it's in it's closed position but
let's say something causes it to open
and we'll talk of maybe in this video or
maybe this video in the next about the
different things that could cause it to
open maybe it's some type of stimulus
causes to open actually there's a whole
bunch of different stimuluses that would
cause it to open but let's say it opens
what's going to happen if it opens well
if it opens so let's say we open it some
stimulus opens what's going to happen
we're more positive on the outside in
the inside so positive things want to
move in and this is a sodium gate so it
only it can only only sodium can go
through it so it's kind of a convoluted
protein structure that only sodium can
make its way through and on top of that
we have a lot more sodium on the outside
than on the inside so the diffusion
gradient is going to want to make sodium
go through it and the fact that sodium
is a positive ion the outside is more
positive they're going to want to run
away from that positive ion from that
positive environment so if you open this
you're just going to have a lot of
sodium ions start to flood through
they're just going to start flooding
through a ton of sodium ions are going
to flood through now as that happens
what's going to happen if we go further
down the membrane let's zoom out let's
zoom out so let's say that this is my
membrane right there let's say that this
is my open gate right here and that it's
open for some reason and a bunch of
sodium is flowing in so all of this is
becoming much more positive much more
positive let's say we had a voltmeter
let's say we had a voltmeter right here
we're measuring the potential difference
between the inside of the membrane and
the outside so let me do a let me do a
little chart let me do a chart so I'm
going to do the chart here my voltmeter
and on this this is going to be the
potential difference or we'll call it
the membrane voltage membrane voltage
or the voltage difference across the
membrane and let's say this is time and
let's say right now let's say I haven't
opened this gate yet so it's in its
resting state are our sodium potassium
pumps or working things are leaking back
and forth but it's staying at that minus
70 millivolts so that right there is
minus 70 millivolts now as soon as this
opens as soon as this gate that's way
down some other part of the cell opens
what's going to happen and let's say
that's the only thing that's open so
this all of a sudden is going to become
more positive so positive charge that's
already here so other positive charges
whether they're sodium's
let me stick to the same color schema
I've been doing whether they're sodium's
or potassium they're going to want to
run away from that point because this
area hasn't had a flood of positive
things so it's less positive than this
over here so maybe we have some
potassium and maybe we have some
sodium's everything is going to want to
move away from the place where this is
opened everything is going to the charge
is going to want to move away so as soon
as this happens as soon as we open this
gate we're going to have a movement of
positive charge in this direction so all
of a sudden this was you know at minus
70 millivolts some more positive charge
is coming its way so it's immediately
almost immediately because these charge
is going to push on each other almost
immediately it's going to become less
negative or more positive it's the
potential difference between this and
this is going to become less so this is
at this point over here now now if we
took this point if we took if we did the
same thing let me do it in a different
color if we measured the voltage at this
point right here maybe it was at minus
70 millivolts maybe a fraction of a
minut amount of time later it the
positive charge starts affecting it so
it becomes more positive but the effect
is diluted right because this positive
charges are going to radiate in every
direction so the effect is diluted so
the effect on this thing is going to be
less it's going to become less positive
so in an electro tonic potential what
happens is at one point in the cell a
gate opens charge starts flooding in and
it starts affecting the potential at
other parts of the cell but the positive
of it is it's very fast it's very fast
so the
is fast right as soon as this happens
further down further down inside this is
the inside of the cell this is inside
further down the cell it starts becoming
more and more positive but the further
you go the effect gets dissipated so you
could say the effect dissipates effect
dissipates with distance so you if you
care about speed you would want this
electrotonic potential as soon as it
happens it will start affecting the rest
of the cell but if you want it if you
wanted this a potential change to travel
over large distances for example let's
say if we get all the way to this point
of the neuron and we wanted to measure
it it might not have any impact maybe a
little bit later but it's not having any
impact because all of this gets diluted
by the time it gets it's increasing the
charge throughout the cell so it's an
impact for a far away from the initial
place where the gate open is going to be
a lot less so it's really not good for
operating over distance now let's let's
try to figure out what's going on with
an action potential and you might
understand this might involve more
action so let's start off with the same
situation we have a sodium gate we have
a sodium gate that gets opened by some
stimulus but what I'm going to do let me
draw two membranes here let me draw so
this is the outside of this is the
outside this is the inside and let me
draw you know maybe we're dealing with a
and we'll go in more detail maybe this
is an axon or something but let me say
that it let's say it looks like that
let's say we have another sodium gate
right here let's say we have a sodium
gate right here and then they they're
alternating essentially so there's
they're alternating so then I have
another I have another sodium gate I was
going to draw another membrane the other
side of the cell but I think I could
just draw them alternating like this so
I have another sodium gate right there
sodium gate right there and I won't I
don't want to do a bunch of these I
think I just have to draw one round of
it for you to get what's going on
and let me draw another potassium gate
another potassium gate just like
at all right and let's say that they all
start closed so they're all in the
closed position now let's say that this
sodium gate gets stimulated it gets
opened so this guy right here gets let's
say that guy right there gets open it
gets stimulated by something to get open
we'll talk about the things it's Tamila
well let's let's say in particular this
thing gets opened so let's say that
sodium gate sodium ion gate open let's
say the stimulus it has to be a certain
voltage and let's say they get they get
they become open when we are at minus 55
millivolts at I'll write the word at at
minus 55 millivolts so when we're just
in our just our resting state the
potential difference from the inside of
the cell and the outside is minus 70 so
it's not going to be open it's going to
be closed but if the but if for whatever
reason this becomes positive enough to
get to minus 55 millivolts all of a
sudden this thing will be open let's
write a couple of other a couple of
other rules that dictate what happens to
this gate let's say it closes let's say
it closes and these are all rough
numbers with the main idea is for you to
get the general idea let's say it closes
at I don't know plus let's say it closes
at plus and Oh 35 35 millivolts and
let's say that our let's say that our
potassium gate opens let's say it opens
at plus 30 40 millivolts just to give an
idea of things and let's say it closes
potassium gate closes at I don't know -
minus eighty millivolts so what's going
to happen let's say that for whatever
reason the voltage here has now become
minus fifty five let me do a chart just
like I did down here so I want to have
space to draw my chart so chart just
like I had here just like I had there
this is membrane voltage membrane
voltage and this this is time down here
and let's say we're measuring it
let's say this is a membrane voltage at
let's say right by the sodium gate right
here so we're measuring this voltage
across this right here so if it's not
stimulated in any way we're just here
flatlining at minus 70 millivolts and
let's say some stimulus for whatever
reason makes this more positive maybe
it's some type of electrotonic effect
that's making it more positive here
maybe some positive charges are floating
by so this becomes more positive so
let's say this becomes more positive and
then the ATP pumps the the the sodium
potassium pumps pump it out so it
doesn't get to the threshold of minus 55
so then nothing will happen right it
didn't get to the threshold but then
let's say there's another electrotonic
or maybe a bunch of them and then just
there's a lot of positive charge here so
we get to the minus 55 we get to the
minus 55 millivolts
remember when positive charge comes by
we become less negative the potential
difference becomes less negative we get
to that minus 55 volts this thing start
this thing opens then right this was
closed before it was closed when we were
just at minus 70 so let me write here so
at this point our let me make that arrow
nicer at this point our sodium gate gate
opens now what's going to happen when
our sodium gate opens when that opens
we've seen this show before all the
positively charged sodium is going to go
down they're both electric gradient and
diffusion gradient and they're going to
flood into the cell they're going to
flood into the cell there's so much
sodium out there so positive out there
they just want to come in so as soon as
you hit that threshold even though even
though you know this might have only
gotten is to minus 55 or maybe minus 50
all of a sudden that gate opens and we
have all of this positive charge
flooding into the cell so the potential
difference becomes much much more
positive so it becomes much much more
positive so they keep flooding in
becomes much much more positive but as
it gets more positive we says it closes
at plus 35 millivolts so let's say let
me clear some of this well actually I
don't to clear that well let me clear it
just because I want to make this I want
to so let me clear that there just so I
can make my graph nicely so let's say
that we're dealing here let's say
that this up here is plus 35 millivolts
so here it closes and at the same time
that stuff I just deleted I said at plus
40 millivolts or let's say it plus 35
just for the sake of argument say it
plus 35 millivolts our sodium gates gate
open so what's happened here all of a
sudden so we're at plus 35 or maybe plus
40 millivolts so this is plus let's just
say plus 40 I think you get the idea
either way so we'll say plus 40 plus 40
either way so at plus 40 this guy is
going to close so this guy shuts down
no more positive ions are coming in but
now we are more positive inside at least
locally at this point on the membrane
than we are outside and so this gate
will open so then our sodium gate will
open k plus ion gate opens now when that
opens what happens we have all of these
sodium ions here there's we already saw
from the sodium potassium pump that the
sorry that the potassium we have all
these potassium ions here we saw from
the sodium potassium pump that it makes
the sodium concentration on the outside
higher and the potassium concentration
on the inside higher and now that we've
gotten to this plus 40 millivolt range
we're also now more positive on the
inside so this opens these guys want to
escape because there's less potassium
outside they want to go down their
concentration gradient and it's also
very positive on the inside we're at
plus 40 millivolts so they also want to
escape so they start escaping the cell
so positive charges starts exiting the
cell from the inside to the outside so
we become less positive again we become
less positive so let me write what
happens here so at this point our sodium
gate closes and our potassium gate opens
our potassium gate opens and then the
positive charge starts flooding out of
the cell again starts flooding out of
the cell and maybe it'll overshoot
because it's not it's only going to
close maybe once we get to minus eighty
millivolts so maybe our potassium gate
closes at minus eighty so okay let me
scroll down
K+ closes gate closes and then and then
our sodium potassium pump might get us
back to our minus 70 millivolts so this
is what's happening just at just at this
point in the cell just across you know
near near that first sodium gate but
what's going to happen in general right
as this became very positive we went to
40 millivolts over here we went to 40
millivolts in this area of the cell
because of I guess you can almost view
it as a short-term or a very short
distance electrotonic potential this
area is going to become more positive
right this is going to become more
positive positive charges are going to
go whether it's less positive so this is
going to become more positive
this wasn't minus 70 but it's going to
become more positive it'll go to minus
65 minus 60 minus 55 and then BAM this
guy will get triggered again then this
guy gets opened then this guy gets open
sodium floods in through here so if you
wanted to plot this guy's the potential
difference of what's going on what's
going on across this this all happened
as soon as you know maybe as as soon as
the sodium started going in this first
dude the second guy he gets triggered
here because at the second guy a little
bit later in time a little bit later in
time because of all this flow a little
bit to the left of him his potential
goes up he gets triggered same exact
thing happens to him right when the
sodium flows in here becomes really
positive around here that makes the the
the cell around here the voltage around
here the charge around here a little bit
more positive triggers this next sodium
gate to open and then this whole same
thing happens same cycle then the
potassium gates open to make it negative
again but by the time that's happened
it's become positive over here to
trigger another sodium gate so one after
another you have these sodium gates
opening and closing but it's
transmitting that information is
transmitting that potential change so
what's going on here so this is slower
and it actually involves energy so this
was the electrotonic was very fast this
is slow an action potential is slower I
don't want to say it's slow it's slower
because it has to involve these opening
and closing of gates and it also
involves energy
it also requires more energy more energy
you have opening and closing of gates
and you're also going to have to keep
changing the potential in your cell and
you actively have your your sodium
potassium pumps being very active but
it's good the positive is it's good at
covering distance covering distance when
you have something like this we saw the
electro tonic as we get further and
further away from where the stimulus
happened the change in potential becomes
more and more dissipate it's actually
exponentially declines it's becomes more
and more dissipated as we get further
and further away so it's not good for
long distance this thing this thing can
just continue forever because every time
it stimulates the next gate it's like
we're starting all over again and so
this gate it's going to have a flood of
ions come in then those ions are going
to make it a little bit more a little
less negative over here then the next
gate is going to open we're going to
have the cycle over and over again so
this is really good for travelling long
distances so now we have really the
foundation to understand exactly what's
happening in a neuron and I'm going to
go over that in the next video to show
you how electrotonic potential and
action potentials can combine to have a
signal travel through a neuron